hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reading your
comments first off I'd like to say thank
you guys so much for putting up with the
completely [ __ ] sporadic upload
schedule I know it's been crazy and not
consistent and some of you may not even
know I have a regular upload schedule of
eight and twelve Pacific Standard Time
every single day that's when I'm
supposed to put out new videos and
that's what I intend to do because me
and the guys we've been working very
hard on compilations highlight reels new
original sketches music videos really
cool new stuff that you guys are going
to love and we've been working very hard
in the behind the scenes area of our
house starting tomorrow we will have
regular uploads 8 and 12 Pacific
Standard Time
every single day and I promise you here
I will never miss another scheduled
upload barring an emergency trip to the
hospital or something exploding but
besides that everything will be
consistent from here on out and
especially these videos every Monday
noon oh and also before I begin I've got
a new shirt that's coming out very soon
it's king of the squirrels it's gonna be
the next charity shirt that comes out
for the market by our heroes stuff and
it will be real soon it's not available
yet sorry if you saw my underwear I
don't wear pants when I record but
that's another story until I'm gonna get
back to the subject of the fur I don't
know if you even read this but if you
could spend a week at a place of choice
with a person you really like to meet
with where who and what would you do
or is that what where and who would you
do or is it who what where would you do
I think I already covered this in my
universe sandbox video but if I could go
anywhere anywhere at all it would be
Mars like i/o if I could be the first
person to stand on Mars oh that would be
coolest thing ever and with who it
doesn't matter who another clone of
myself but a female no good Jill that's
getting into some uncharted territory
anyway the Mars the Mars
and myself but a female clone myself uh
I guess that's my answer
moving on please try to speak Dutch
please I don't know what Dutch sounds
like hang on I got to find some Dutch I
am the most mature person I know
hello my name is panis kazoo and that
means hello my name is penis face
there we go that's some Dutch for you
that was oddly close to English mark
tell your mom you're gonna have a baby
or you're fried what guess I could call
my mom I think oh I've been forwarded to
an O I know I could call my stepmom Oh
she usually answers okay hey I'm gonna
call Miss Emma hello hi how's it going
good how are you good apparently I'm
going to have a baby
okay that's what that's me yeah a baby
puppy
no human baby I see I don't know the
Internet's I think oh okay so someone on
there says you're you're pregnant with
your child
yes that's exactly what they're saying
okay any possibility this is a true
story well I don't know I'd have to look
into it but I'm pretty sure it's true
okay no no and you know anyway I'm sorry
I'm doing a video right now and someone
told me to call my mom and tell them I'm
gonna have a baby so as far as I know
that's not true but you never know whose
genes okay well you know I would love it
and decided not not yet not for dinner
yeah unfortunately it won't be a that
won't be soon from me but maybe Thomas
there's a
was hope no no no there's no hope okay
okay dear we'll talk to you later okay
okay
love you love you too hi that's my
stepmom
she's awesome just like the best sorry
mom if my mom's watching this Hey
you didn't answer the phone Oh No
markiplier is gonna die
he isn't healthy r.i.p mark emu oh I
didn't
hey Mark what's artist part of a
vegetable the wheelchair you know your
offensive jokes don't really have as
much candor when you shot them at the
top of your lungs I don't think I use
the word candor properly but I don't
care I like your new white and gold
background hey Mark did you learn to
edit your videos on your own yes I did
when I started making videos I had
absolutely no idea what I was doing and
you know a lot of people often asked
like oh how do you make videos oh how do
you do this it's actually a lot simpler
than it seems
it just takes like a series of goals you
need to set for yourself and then a
series of exploration that you need to
do like when you're making a video you
always go like oh I can imagine this
thing in my head I just need to figure
out how to do that in the program so
it's a lot of trial and error but over
three years I've gotten to the point
where I can make sick edits like this
and Wow and oh what was that what's that
an aardvark cool it's almost like it was
really here what is your biggest regret
in your YouTube job career Wow that's
getting pretty deep there I have to
think about that one I I think my
biggest regret you know sometimes in the
past I've said like oh when you play
video games for a living it's not as fun
to play them but I still play video
games so it's not really that I'd say
the biggest regret is that this job has
moved me out to LA and it's taken me
away from my family and my friends and
not that you know I wouldn't do it again
I would do it again I don't regret
moving out here but I do regret not
being able to hang out with like my
close friends that I know from high
school and stuff and my family who's
very important to me and my brother
who's like my best friend you know
there's a lot of things that I miss from
having them back in Cincinnati and
someday I will go back to Cincinnati but
right now you know I'm at this point in
my life where I have to do a whole lot
more with what I have because if I don't
take advantage of the gifts that I've
been given then it's going to waste so I
got to make sure I do as much as I can
now so that they don't regret more in
the future know what I mean so that's
probably long story short I regret
nothing
give me food I've got easy I've got easy
cheese take it I missed he is easy
jeez easy cheese for your face mmm this
is how Americans eat cheese apparently
not me though I only have this by my
desk for comedic purposes no branding
hey Mark I just want to say thank you
I've had my fair share of hardships
throughout my life and you always
managed to put a smile on my face thank
you for making awesome content for
people to laugh rage in the comments
facepalm and keep up the good work and
also horse [ __ ]
sorry had to say something ridiculous or
would have gone nuts horse nuts
thanks Bruce Wang donkey kong making
people smiles like my number one goal
whenever I'm making videos like I don't
set out to do something absolutely
amazing every time I make a video but I
always try to make videos that will make
people smile or laugh in one way or
another and just like yesterday when I
was making the video with chica where
she was just running around the yard in
slow motion like that was just off the
cuff a whim of mine you know I was bored
in the morning and I was just like hey I
want to make something different today
and I have this camera that can do
slow-motion so why not take video of the
durable 3d Bobby chica who you beauty
Wooper yup ever do pop yes she's the
cutest puppy pup to ever turn up that's
what I said I love that video especially
because after it went up I did nothing
but read the comments and then read on
other social media pages about how
people enjoyed it and loved it and we're
so happy to see and how it cheered
people up and how apparently look just
like a dog food commercial nothing was
sold by that video by the way just in
case people are curious but it's just
like something like that that I can make
in just a few hours can make a bunch of
people smile and that is probably the
greatest thing about YouTube how many
subscribers do you think you can get
I've kind of stopped worrying about that
I mean of course I can say that I'm in a
position where I have over 10 million
subscribers I don't have to worry about
subscribers but frankly I kind of
stopped worrying about how many
subscribers I had a long time ago
because for a while there like maybe a
year into YouTube I was really in the
subscriber race I was very very antsy
about getting more subscribers I was
very antsy about growing my channel and
for a lot of reasons but mostly it was
just because vanity I think and then
right around the video that this
happened was ripe as to fears but I had
this realization that
I originally set out to do it just for
the sake of doing it and then I got
caught up in the subscriber race and
ever since then I've tried to always
keep in perspective exactly why I'm
doing this and one of the reasons is
charity the other reasons is to make
people smile the third and most
important reason probably is for me to
just have fun and enjoy it and work with
great people and get cool opportunities
to do cool new things like that's the
best part that's the only reason that
people should do YouTube just because I
have tons of subscribers doesn't mean
that other people can't have fun and do
YouTube and learn creative things and
explore new artistic means every single
day that's what I get to do it's
literally the greatest thing that's ever
happened to my life and that's never
gonna be an exaggeration it's amazing
and thank you guys for letting me do it
are there going to be more challenges
with Mathias yes I aim to do something
with Mathias very soon I think he said
to me recently he was busy with the 12
days of Matt mesma thymus met math may
have been so as soon as he's done with
that I should be able to squeeze in some
recording sessions with him I want to go
up with Matt and Ryan and hopefully if
we can do some more lip-reading
challenge and seven second challenge
because that would be super super fun
why we love boobs I've said many times
and I'll say it again if I had boobs I
would do nothing else with my life but
play with my boobs are you that
exterminator of stoners yes can you feel
the love tonight
I know oh do you have a girlfriend mark
not at the moment thank you I have no
intentions of getting your girlfriend
anytime soon because I just got out of a
long-term relationship with a lovely
girl by the name of Jess we're still
friends she's totally awesome but I'm
not really looking for anything right
now oh hello hello hi oh yeah I just
called you because apparently the
internet wanted me to tell you that I
had a baby ah yeah apparently hi I have
a baby
when I don't know it's gonna happen
should be born in a few months
oh no I don't know I have no idea
oh you you a baby
uh yes how'd that happen I don't know I
you never explained it to me as a kid I
don't know then who's the mother of dad
I don't know is your baby
apparently oh okay now you gotta yeah
the the internet asked the question I'm
doing the video right now mom the
internet asked a question and they
wanted me to tell call you and tell you
that I'm having a baby
oh okay congratulation I hope it looks
just like you
okay thanks thanks mom I forget that you
und both want me to have a baby oh yeah
I want to have a grandson just like you
just like me internet superstar
markiplier jr. huh is that Lucy yeah
Lucy Lucy I might bring chica back home
uh over winter break she look like a
little sexually yeah she's got really
white fur I'm looking forward to seeing
my grandson ah not gonna happen anytime
soon
asked Thomas there's some hope in Thomas
you never know you never know I think I
got you you know you know that I know
yeah I know I wasn't supposed to be born
I get it yep it happened because I don't
know what happened
hi I was an unwanted baby I planned my
best but I guess the upper high powers
that know you're gonna have my
now that's not a pun okay okay honey
love you love you too bye-bye
but mark I know you cannot drink but
have you ever tried LSD if not would you
ever that's a big jump to go from booze
straight to LSD no I've never tried LSD
let's not get out that that that's not
know I've never topic comments no I have
not
mark please sing this Oh God will I love
ya
I'll stop singing forever actually oddly
enough I just got my music set up
already and going cuz uh III III III
I've always wanted to make music and so
I've been building this little music
creation station and hopefully hopefully
I'll be able to play around with it in
the coming weeks and maybe maybe make
something for you guys I don't know
maybe I'll sing for real and not for
jokesters so anyway maybe probably not
okay all right so that's all for reading
your comments this week thank you
everybody so much for watching and
remember you can't write comments in the
description no matter how many times I
tell you to do so write your comments
down in the comment section below and I
might just put it on the next video you
never know
I do enjoy reading through them all so
thank you everybody who did not get on
this particular episode but thank you
nonetheless for running comment your
weird weird people but also heartwarming
and beautiful so thank you everybody
again keep an eye out for when this goes
on sale it'll be a limited release I
think there's only 5,000 of them so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye